(intense music)
- In Kabul streets are full of life.
Markets are busy and even amusement parks
are open for visitors,
including some bemused Taliban fighters.
This street in the Afghan capital Kabul
used to be closed for most
Afghan citizens until recently,
this is where the Afghan
ministry of interior used to be
and where the European union's
mission was also located.
That meant that you get into the street,
you had to pass several
layers of security barriers.
Those barriers have now been taken down
as the Taliban try to
convey a sense of normalcy
in the capital.
- (foreign language)
- But the situation here
is far from back to normal.
The economy is on the verge of collapse
and many Afghans say they don't know
where the next paycheck
is gonna come from.
And it's not just the economy.
Women's freedoms are being taken away.
The Taliban have banned teenage
girls from going to school
and reintroduced harsh
Islamic punishments,
as they shot, and then hung a group of
alleged kidnappers in Herat.
So in many ways,
the reality on the ground here in Kabul
is in contrast to the messages
that the Taliban have been sending.
Since the Taliban took control in August,
fighters have been patrolling the streets,
toting guns and Manning
checkpoints in Kabul.
Their presence demonstrates
military might,
but it's also a way for
the Taliban to convey
that Afghans are safe.
- (foreign language)
- But a recent spate of attacks
is undermining that sense of security.
In Kabul a bomb exploded at
a mosque in early October,
leaving several citizens dead.
No one immediately claimed
responsibility for the attack.
In other parts of the country,
the Taliban had been struggling
to contain the threat
from Islamic state,
which has said it was behind
deadly roadside bombings.
- (foreign language)
- Both the Taliban and Islamic state
want to impose strict
Islamic rules on Afghanistan,
but have deep religious
and political differences.
The Taliban have been trying
to portray a moderate image,
but on the ground, they've
reimposed harsh punishments,
reminiscent of how they
used to rule the country
in the late 1990s.
In the Western city of Herat,
the Taliban killed four men
they accused of being kidnappers.
Then hung them from a public square.
Many Afghans fear the
Taliban's hard-line rule,
especially those who worry
that it will threaten basic freedoms.
- (foreign language)
- Women in particular have borne the brunt
of these new regulations.
The Taliban initially said
that it will allow women to attend school.
- (foreign language)
- But we've seen now
that they've banned girls from
attending secondary school
and women have been
sent home from offices.
In many provinces of the country,
women are no longer
allowed to leave the house
without a male relative escorting
them around the streets.
Many Afghans fear that
the Taliban will ban music
like the date in the 1990s.
Already many Afghans refrain
from playing music in public
and classes have stopped at the renowned
National Institute of Music,
which was home to the country's
first, all female orchestra
- (foreign language)
- As they work out how to govern,
the Taliban have been seeking
to woo the international community
and win diplomatic recognition.
However, most countries have stopped short
of officially recognizing
the Taliban's government
and have suspended aid.
After the Taliban took control,
the US, the IMF and other countries
also froze Afghanistan's
foreign currency reserves,
which the country is heavily reliant on.
And that's had a huge
effect on the economy.
There's a lack of cash
and banks have put a strict limit
on how much money people can withdraw.
That means Afghans don't have enough money
to buy the food that they used to,
and they don't have enough money
to basically keep the economy going.
Before the Taliban came to power,
nearly half the population
lived in poverty,
but it was rare to see scenes like this,
of Afghans struggling to find food
or queuing up outside
ATMs to withdraw cash.
The UN has warned of growing starvation
and pledged 1.2 billion in emergency aid.
- (foreign language)
- Many people who work
for the former government
had lost their jobs.
Unemployment is soaring
and at the same time, prices
of food and fuel are rising,
and Afghans are worried
that the coming winter
is going to be a struggle.